good evening everyone um my name is
manny young and i would love to welcome
you all to pi data global 2021 um i'm
really happy to be here and i'll be the
host
of this session today i would like to
introduce our speaker um today with us
we have megan yao um and she will be
actually giving a talk today on
simplifying testing of spark application
um megan is a data scientist at spotify
and prior to her joining spotify she
worked as a data scientist at um sobres
one of canada's largest grocery
retailers
she's actually a contributor to
i think yeah she's a contributor to fugu
and also an app which is an abstract
layer that keeps code and computation
native to python yet simply
yet easily
possible to spark clusters
um
yep so i think i would just actually
hand it over to you to do the
introduction and maybe i'll increase the
funds over here so over to you megan
thanks uh manny thanks for the
introduction
and yeah today i'll be talking about
simplifying testing of spark
applications
i think a lot of people in the audience
kind of knows a lot about desk and
whatnot spark is a similar kind of
distributed uh computing framework um
uh it's like execution is um slightly is
it's a lot uh more different um but in
the essence and and user experience is
kind of the same trying to achieve the
same thing so actually in my in the
start of my presentation i actually
wanted to go over a demo
um
so i'll start sharing my screen
okay so in my demo here um i would like
to show you a common nlp data processing
task on a data set that i've got from
kaggle
this data set contains a large number of
wikipedia comments it has been labeled
by human readers for varying levels of
toxic behavior
and the reason why and what i wanted to
demonstrate here is two kind of ways of
processing it one using the spark map
and pandas um slash like pandas udf um
way of doing things and the second is
using fugue and what i wanted to
demonstrate here is the um different
ways you can kind of get to the same
kind of result and also showcase a
common kind of like prototyping workflow
and um which is something that i would
love to dive a little bit more into um
and give more context in my presentation
uh later on as to what other workflows
and scenarios that you would come across
when
developing prototyping the spark
applications so as to deploy them later
on
so in this first method of that nlp task
i am
doing the kind of general imports i have
pi spark i have few
i also have pandas and some typing
data types
doing some settings i also have to
instantiate kind of a spark
session in this case and that's because
the map and pandas api slash like pandas
udf
requires you to it runs using spark so i
have to do that
and in this case um i think a lot of
people kind of is familiar with this is
this this is the pandas read csv doesn't
use the spark
cluster just yet and over here i'm just
kind of printing an example of how a
record were to look like so in this nlp
task that i'll be going over it's a
tokenizing task so what that means is
that i'm breaking down these comments
into its individual kind of words and
tokens so over here just
i guess highlighting what that comment
would look like and in this chunk over
here this is really the meat of the
processing task and
as a
data scientist or developer maybe you
wanted to add some
customizability to your tokenizer so it
is very reasonable for you to write this
custom function in
python
using um regex by removing punctuation
by stripping um white spaces by
splitting them on spaces you know
flattening them by um
removing like the new line characters um
removing any non-ascii words and
even using your own kind of
stop word corpus and in this case i am
getting
the corpus from nltk and then removing
those stop words and and then finally um
uh assigning the final list of tokens to
a new column called comment tokens and
one thing to note is that this is done
entirely in in pandas uh data frames so
everything from this point is kind of
running on um on on python
and over here this is where um kind of
like the spark
i guess syntax or pi spark syntax were
to come in so this is where you might
have to okay i want to use like a
distributed framework because i know
that eventually even though i'm kind of
prototyping my logic here in pandas and
making sure that you know i'm able to
kind of run that same function and
tokenize them
in a way where it would split out those
individual comments and you can see that
in here
that i have successfully done it
maybe later on you actually are going to
be processing you know a larger set of
of comments and you want to make sure
that that also runs properly so um in in
that kind of framework you're actually
deploying your um kind of function to
your spark cluster and also making sure
that it can run in a distributed fashion
so what you do here is you um you might
convert your pandas data frame into a
spark data frame where you would make
sure that that
that tokenize function that you've
written you would have to kind of wrap
that into a um
into um this kind of function here so
that it can uh so that you can use the
map and pandas uh api
um to
so i guess process your spark data frame
and spark data frame whenever you you
hear that i would think like um you know
just a way to organize your data so that
when you just run distributed computing
all of these different nodes are able to
kind of know which kinds of partitions
to um to to process your data in
um
so so over here we can also see that yes
i i i'm very happy because i'm able to
get these tokens out very similar to how
i have been prototyping it locally um
so up to this point you would realize
that you would have to have have an
understanding of how to write these kind
of udfs or map and pandas api you would
also have to
realize that it only takes in like
specific data types as well
and in this case it is an iterator
and it can only also take in kind of one
parameter as well so um
uh later on
and oh and another thing is that you
also have to um you know read up a
little bit more about the schema
definition of um
spark data types as well so you know
this is not necessarily python native
and in terms of the developer experience
i would have to kind of uh know how how
how that spark
kind of syntax kind of works in order to
write this
so now i wanted to show you how this
function would be written
um in the framework of fugue so
in terms of schema definition one thing
you would notice is that this is a now
done in the comments uh in a comment
here and what few does it actually
parses this comment to understand how
what data types would be an output would
be an output for and in this case this
is this exact same function so all i had
to do is say i'm going to be adding a
new column that is now a list of string
and
over here this is also
actually python native and it is python
native because i'm using the native
execution engine which is the python
executor in order to run my function so
in this case of my prototyping workflow
this is very similar to me you know
writing my custom function in python and
then testing it locally and then when it
comes to deployment
aka you know running on a larger data
set i am able to kind of swap this and
engine parameter out to spark
execution engine and i only had to do
that when i was ready to to deploy my
function um uh to a smart cluster
and as a developer that's really nice
because i don't have to worry so too
much about you know installing a jvm on
my local machine installing spark on my
local machine i don't even have to
install pi spark actually on my on my
machine in order for the second method
um and
i i will go a little i'll and i'll um
i'll actually actually explain how pi
spark works in a second in my
presentation as well
so just to kind of wrap up this demo um
in this result pdf i am actually
outputting a pandas data frame in this
case and if i want it to run on spark
execution engine and in this case uh
think about me using spark execution
engine on my deployed cluster right and
in this case it actually outputs a spark
data frame so what fugue allows you to
do is kind of switch in between
different kind of execution engines as
and when you need to
and another nice additional kind of
bonus about using fugue is that you're
able to also add in additional
parameters to your tokenize function
so for example if you wanted to
abstract
or if you wanted to parameterize the
column that you're processing your
comments in you can do that whereas in
this case in the
the first method you would have to
change your code in a bunch of different
places so as to allow your uh tokenize
function to take in that input column
parameter you would have to change it
obviously in tokenize you would have to
change it in the map tokenize function
you would have to kind of add it in here
and then over here
once again that restriction of only
taking in one parameter which is the
iterator pandas data frame
so what what this would mean is that you
would probably have to kind of hard code
that in here or
you know
some other way
so yeah so that's kind of the um the
demo that i wanted to demonstrate and in
my presentation i wanted to go over
what's happening under the hood right
like i i think spark has come definitely
a very long way in terms of trying to
improve the native python execution
experience and keeping your functions as
nice python native as possible um so i
wanted to to dive into that and i also
wanted to
break down the different workflows in
order to see to make sure that fugue is
kind of the right fit for you when
you're thinking about you know
developing spark applications and also
handling different kinds of tests in
different scenarios
so i will be switching contacts now
to my presentation
so um as promised i wanted to talk about
how pi spark actually works so um for
those of you who don't know pi spark is
actually
a api
a spark api and what it allows you to do
is write spark applications using python
syntax or the python api
and pi spark supports most of sparks
features such as as you can see here sql
data frame streaming ml lib and the
spark core
but what
what this means and the reason for this
api is because spark is actually written
in scala um and its source code can be
compiled to java bytecode and it has to
be ran on the java virtual machine so
the main takeaway here is that pi spark
is actually not python native so when
you do an import of pi spark and you try
to execute you know pi spark um
apis you're actually relying on
python you know sending instructions to
to be ran on the jvm
um i've ran into like errors if you
don't install your jvm correctly and
things like that um so it could be a
little bit cumbersome when when um
working with pi spark but i overall it
is a very nice way to
kind of access you know spark features
through python and keep your um your
code base very python um syntax friendly
um and this might face a bit of a
problem for data science applications
because most of us like writing in
python right
most data science teams you know are
familiar with lots of python libraries
um and you you you would use like
scikit-learn and whatnot um and all of
those code all that code has to be
executed on you know python uh native
engine um but then when you're right in
pi spot you're actually executing on the
jvm so you actually um have to balance
you know right um have to balance kind
of
two types of logic running on in two
different kinds of environments
so what that means is is that you want
to maintain a balance of things that you
need to maintain and things that you
want
that you also want so
so in this case like i said on the right
you have your python logic where it has
to be ran on the python interpreter and
then you also have your spark logic
which needs to be run on the jvm and
it's good to also think about what kinds
of data that you need and want to
process so on the left you might have
pandas data frames in terms of like mock
data frames where you're you know
running very small unit tests in terms
of um
making sure that your python
functionality works um and then uh on
the
or in terms of like spark data frames
where you're running kind of like an
integration test to make sure that um
kind of your spark application works
end-to-end
so
that brings me to the types of tests
that you want to
write so like i said an integration test
that could be
very similar to kind of making sure that
your overall application runs when you
deploy it in a distributed fashion so
making sure that you know when you
ingest data from your
data lake and
running things in spark making sure that
that runs through together with your
python logic and your sparklogic
and unit tests and
unit tests which is you know writing
kind of small modular pieces of code to
make sure every individual function kind
of works so as to give your future kind
of data scientists and developers
confidence to contribute to your code
base and then the last kind of
test which is
more subtle
but very
important to your developer experience
is like type checks making sure that you
know you have the right kinds of data
types that are
the right kinds of data types that you
expect so that when you deploy your
spark applications in production you are
your code base is expecting this the
same kinds of data types that
you have a developed fit for
um
yeah so let's break that down so that's
kind of like all of the different things
that you want and you need so let's kind
of break that down into
this 2x2 table
in order to
kind of understand the different
scenarios of how you'd be processing
data and how that affects your
kind of execution time
so on the top left you have like a
pandas data frame and your python logic
and that's the easiest test because
there's no cluster spin up and on the
right hand side um you have your spark
data frame and your python logic you
might have to encounter a spark uh
your cluster spin up because your data
frames are already partitioned in a
spark data frame format you might have
to convert your spark data frame to
pandas which can be very expensive
depending on the size of your data
and in fact you might run into memory
issues so what some developers have done
very similar to my demo is either wrap
your python functionality into a pandas
udf or use the map in pandas api
and that way you can successfully extend
functionality of pi spark yet
be able to write
you know python functions and be able to
use python libraries
the only thing is that has to be
serializable
so it might be a bit cumbersome to test
on this type of functionality and it
also might be expensive
um and i'll go into a little bit more
about udfs later on and then on the
bottom left you have your pandas data
frame and your spark logic and this is
the case where maybe you might not think
you would run into this ever but um a
small i guess like a comment uh one
scenario could be that you have your
pandas mock data frames and you have
your kind of like spark logic that has
to be coupled with like some python
logic together with the spark lodging
and because of that you would still have
to encounter a cluster spin up because
spark logic has to run on the spark
cluster
and then
because of that you also have to convert
your pandas data frame to a smart data
frame and that might be cumbersome to
test as well because of that data
conversion
and then finally um you have the spark
and spark and in this case you're pretty
happy but you also have to encounter a
local spark cluster spin out
so
like i said udfs and pandas udf they
might kind of come into the rescue of
of saving you that data conversion
because instead of um
converting your spark data frames to
pandas what
spark actually has thought about is
serializing your python
function so that it is is able to run on
different worker nodes um and actually
has seen a lot of improvements and i
wanted to also talk a little bit about
the evolution of
being able to run your python
native
functionality on spark and how that has
improved over time
so the first kind of improvement is that
running your python logic will now
encounter less time so prior to spark
2.3 i know we're at spark 3.2 so this is
a little bit of like three or four three
years in history um so in spark 2.3
you have the improvement of the pandas
udf so what that means is that it um it
sparked work used um the apache aero
project in order to
help serialize some of these um
functions
or i guess like reserves the right to
determine how to partition your pandas
series
so
what that means is that in the past it
your pi like spark doesn't know what
your python function does right so in
order to be as
conservative as possible it actually
processes your data one row at a time so
that's what you see in the blue bars
here and
in spark 2.3 they came out with the
pandas udf
that actually allows them to
instead of um i guess processing things
one row at a time it recognizes that you
know things can be in a in a series in a
column column or format and it can kind
of partition it in a way where the
workers can run kind of chunks of data
and not just one row at a time so
what that means in terms of performance
is huge performance gains and as you can
see the largest performance gain in this
case is the cdf function which is a
cumulative distribution function
that is
taken from scipy
so in scipy
it is a python package so that's one of
the reasons why i wanted to talk about
this it's another really nice way of
extending and bringing in python
functionality into spark
so all you can see here is that the
pandas udf outperforms the vanilla
original udf
so second improvement they've made is
that it allows for python type hands so
why that's great for testability is that
you are able to write
python native type hints
keeping your your python functions even
more native as it should be
and um
yeah one thing to note is that
on the left here
you can see that in the past you could
write them as pandas udf decorators
as well and you have to also specify
like a specific udf types and there's
there was a lot of confusion as to know
which type to use
what is the concept of like a group map
function and how how to make sure when
you're using things in the right way so
the third the third evolution here is it
actually reduced the kind of confusion
as to you know which um kind of way to
to use things in by introducing the map
and pandas uh api
so in this case there
we have we we're using kind of like the
um we we don't have to uh use like the
um the pandas udf kind of decorator in
this case um it keeps that function as
python friendly as possible and like i
said in the
in the start of this
presentation in the demo when you use
the python
pandas udf in order to access the python
native function again you need to read a
bit of source code to uncover how to get
to it so this actually is really nice
because my function is kind of
unadulterated from all that
decorator and unadulterated for for any
kind of like spark kind of syntax
um
so
this is actually kind of cumbersome to
test still and because we're um i guess
one day away from halloween this this
might be a little bit spooky to you
because you still have to the the
hauntings of writing additional tests
still has to still still comes into play
because um in this case
your first function of like this is an
example of a um
of a model that you're
scoring like different kinds of um like
data frames on and in this case this
first function is python native as you
can see there's no kind of like spark
implementation here it has to run on a
python execution engine and in the
second part we have to kind of
declare like our schema types and use
the mapping pandas api where it has to
use the spark execution engine and
thereby having to write two different
tests for it
um
so that's not great in in terms of like
your testing
experience
and the last point i wanted to drive
home is that even though you might be
able to spin up you know a local
spark cluster
some people might be familiar with data
breaks and if you aren't it is actually
founded by the original creators of
apache spark and it allows developers to
just kind of spin up a remote cluster at
a click of a button and they also have
this client library called the data
databricks connect that allows you to
run your pi spark um
hi manny i know i have five minutes left
and i'm trying to speed through this
and it allows you to run your
it allows you to run your pi spark
functions uh locally but also um send
those instructions to a remote cluster
um and that's sometimes really nice
because you're able to prototype right
on your production environment but in a
very kind of local kind of setting like
in vs code or whatnot um the downside
about databricks connect is that the
first step of installing the client
library is to actually uninstall pi
spark which means that
you you no longer take like one or two
seconds to spin up a pi spark uh to spin
up a local spark cluster you might have
to wait a little bit longer because you
have to wake up the end of the remote
cluster on data breaks
so i know some of you are waiting as if
you know you're trick-or-treating and
you're waiting for what the punch line
is here so i wanted to introduce you
which is an abstraction a framework that
allows users to write code native in
python or pandas and port it over to
spartgardask which are a distributed
computing frameworks it allows you to
keep your python logic as native as
possible as you have seen in the demo
and keep
and and also keep those functions
testable and there's no need for cluster
spin up unless warranted
and some of these additional benefits of
using fugue is that we have the
guarantee on consistency we understand
that when you do specific
functionalities on pandas and on spark
you might run into different um kind of
you might run into different
results we make sure that we are
consistent according to on those
frameworks
and also another benefit is that you are
able to
save on some
development and even execution time and
what i mean is that let's say you have
functions c d and e that uses the same
helper function b
so when you're computing
c d and e
fugue is has a
special feature called the auto persist
that allows you to
save on some time of computing b three
times
and then lastly um
sorry um you just have two minutes left
and i think
if you can also use that to answer the
current questions we have
okay yeah sure um this is my final slide
so i'll just quickly go over through
this and then go to the questions
so um on the
um
schema validation
this is also really nice because it
allows you to fail fast you don't have
to kind of run into these errors when
you're you're executing
later on on remotely you're able to know
that
this
data type is wrong and you're able to
kind of fix that while you're
prototyping
you're able to contact us through we
have our
links here you can reach out to us on
slack we have documentation and our
project is found on github
um i'm no
spotify and fugue um
these are kind of like my two separate
worlds but because i work at spotify
if you see any kind of interesting jobs
let me know i'm happy to answer any
questions
and um yeah i will go to the q a now so
uh what is the key difference between
spark 2 and spark 3. um
i guess this one um
this there's very a lot of different
differences actually um so the one that
uh i guess like i
you would care mo the most about would
be
um i guess how it impacts the
ability for
um python developers to extend spark
functionality and
i would say in spark 2.3 that was kind
of like the main difference there where
it allows you to write
python
pandas udfs and
map and pandas apis and allows you for a
lot faster computation time um
yeah
great thank you very much megan um
so i think if we have any other
questions anything to ask so we can move
over to the slack channel and continue
our discussions over there thank you
once again megan for the talk